The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Hi, and welcome
to 5.07 biochemistry online.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
Now, I have here
problem two of problem
set three, which is
an excellent exercise
about the mechanism of
inhibition of enzymes,
specifically proteases.
Now, this deals with
the same protease
from problem one of this problem
set, which is interleukin
converting enzyme, or ICE.
Therefore, it's best that
you familiarize yourself
with the mechanism of
action of this enzyme, ICE,
by solving problem 1 and then
continuing with this video,
here.
As you found out by
solving problem one,
ICE is a cysteine protease.
It features cysteine and a
histidine in its active site.
The mechanism starts
by the histidine
acting as a general base and
deprotonates the cysteine SH
group.
The thiolate anion
then can attack
the substrate, forming first,
a tetrahedral intermediate.
When this tetrahedral
intermediate collapses,
it cleaves the peptide
bond and accomplishes
the chemical reaction
of the protease.
Then, the newly
formed thioester is
hydrolyzed to release the
other half of the product.
Let's take a look
at the mechanism.
Here is our peptide substrate.
And this is the
peptide bond that's
going to be cleaved by protease.
As we mentioned, we have a
cysteine in the active site
and we have a histidine
that's just going
to function as a general base.
I'm going to denote it as B.
In the first step,
the histidine is going
to deprotonate the cysteine.
The cysteine is
then going to attack
the carbonyl of
our peptide bond,
and the electrons are
going to go to the oxygen,
and form a tetrahedral
intermediate.
Here, notice the histidine
is going to be protonated,
and the oxygen is going
to have a negative charge.
In the next step, this
tetrahedral intermediate
is going to fall
apart by breaking
the peptide bond that the
protease is supposed to cleave.
There is the thioester with
the cysteine in the active site
and one half of our product
is going to be released, here.
Once again, the
histidine is going
to be deprotonated at this step.
In the second
step, the thioester
we just formed in
the active site
will be hydrolyzed by
a water molecule, which
will be activated by the same
histidine in the active site.
Here is our water molecule.
So, the histidine is going
to deprotonate the water,
activating it for attack on the
carbonyl, forming once again,
a tetrahedral intermediate.
I have a negative charge
here and a positive charge
on the histidine.
Finally, this
tetrahedral intermediate
will collapse, restoring the
cysteine in the active site,
which can be reprotonated
by the protonated histidine,
and releasing the second
half of our substrate, here.
So there you have it.
Now we restored the active
site with the cysteine
and the histidine.
And this is the second half of
our peptide that we cleaved.
So notice the carboxyl
side is right here
and the amine side was
released a little bit earlier.
The mechanism that
you just saw is
very similar to
the serine protease
mechanism that is
described in the book
and in the lecture notes.
Notice, every time we form
a tetrahedral intermediate,
this is probably
stabilized in an oxyanion
hole formed by some
of the residues
on the backbone of the enzyme.
Now let's take a
look at a couple
of strategies for inhibiting
a cysteine protease like ICE.
This problem is
proposing two strategies.
One involves an
aldehyde inhibitor,
the other involving an acyl
methyl ketone inhibitor.
Let's take a look.
Here is the structure of a
proposed aldehyde inhibitor.
Notice here, this is a aspartate
residue, or aspartate looking
residue, which together with
the other couple of amino acids,
forms the recognition
portion of the inhibitor
that we're allowing
to bind the protease.
The R group is going to
be an aldehyde, which
will be crucial for actually
inhibiting the enzyme.
Question one of this
problem is asking
us to propose a
mechanism by which
the aldehyde inhibitor works.
We're given an
important clue that this
is a mechanism based inhibitor.
A mechanism based
inhibitor means
that the inhibitor binds
in the same fashion
as the normal substrate
of the enzyme.
Therefore, after
we have reviewed
the mechanism of the
cysteine protease
and remembering some of
our carbonyl chemistry,
we should be able to propose
the following chemical reaction.
Here is the active
site of our protease.
This is the cysteine and
this is the histidine,
which we're denoting
as a general base, B.
And here's our
aldehyde inhibitor,
which I'm going to just show
the aldehydic group, right here.
Since the R group
next to this aldehyde
resembles very closely
the natural substrate
of the enzyme,
this aldehyde group
will be positioned in the same
place where we would normally
find the peptide bond that
will be cleaved by the enzyme.
Therefore, this thiolate
group, once it forms,
will be in great position
to react with the aldehyde
and form a tetrahedral
intermediate.
Therefore, the histidine
deprotonates the cysteine,
and the cysteine can
then attack the carbonyl
to form a tetrahedral
intermediate.
Therefore, we get this
tetrahedral intermediate
and a protonated histidine base.
Now normally, the reaction
would proceed from here
to form a thioester, but
because this is an aldehyde,
the reaction stops
here, and that's
how the enzyme will be
inhibited because we have now
bound this inhibitor.
We'll have it covalently
bound in the active site
to this cysteine.
An interesting observation,
which you can't really
tell from the problem,
when people looked
at the x-ray structure of
this tetrahedral intermediate,
they noticed that the negative
charge on the oxygen is not,
in fact, stabilized
in the oxyanion hole
that would stabilize such
tetrahedral intermediates
for the normal reaction.
The ability of
the aldehyde group
to react with the cysteine
in the active site
and form a covalent
bond can readily
explain why the molecule would
function as an inhibitor.
Nevertheless, the reaction
between the aldehyde
and the nucleophile,
the thiolate,
is readily reversible.
So whenever the inhibitor
is in its carbonyl form,
it can potentially fall off from
the active site of the enzyme.
Therefore, how good
of an inhibitor
this molecule is will
depend on how tight
it binds to the enzyme, and
not necessarily on the fact
that it forms a covalent
bond in the active site.
This is an example of
a reversible inhibitor,
even though it forms a
covalent bond with the enzyme.
Therefore, its ability
to inhibit an enzyme
will depend on the
relative concentration
between the inhibitor
and the natural substrate
of the enzyme.
Let's remember the
Michaelis-Menten equation
written for a
reversible inhibitor.
As you recall, we have an enzyme
reacting with a substrate.
We have k1 and k
minus 1 the rate
constant to form the enzyme
substrate complex, which
then with k2, is going
to form the product
and reform the enzyme.
But the inhibitor will
react with the enzyme
in the absence of the
substrate in an equilibrium,
forming an enzyme
inhibitor complex which
does not lead to any product.
The constant of
this equilibrium,
I'm going to call
it Ki, and this
is the dissociation constant of
the enzyme inhibitor complex.
As you have seen in
the notes, the rate,
taking into account the
inhibition constant here,
the rate v is going to be
Vmax times the concentration
of the substrate over Km.
This is Michaelis
constant for the enzyme.
Times 1 plus
concentration of inhibitor
over Ki plus concentration
of substrate, s.
Now, this equation
tells us exactly how
the rate is going to
change as we increase
or decrease the concentration
of the inhibitor.
Notice here, that this term
is always greater than 1
because concentration and Ki are
going to be positive numbers.
So this is 1 plus
something positive.
It's always going to
be greater than 1,
therefore, the denominator
is going to be bigger
than if we had Km
times 1 plus s.
So in the absence
of the inhibitor,
the denominator is
going to be Km plus s.
Therefore, when we
add the inhibitor,
this denominator gets
bigger, and therefore
the whole fraction gets smaller.
We get a smaller rate.
This is the basis for why
the inhibitor will inhibit
the enzyme, and therefore
the rate of the reaction
is going to be smaller.
To see this graphically,
we can write
the reciprocal of the equation
and look at the Lineweaver-Burk
plot.
The reciprocal of the equation
is going to be 1/v equals--
and if we crunch
the numbers, going
to come up with Km/Vmax
times 1 plus I/Ki times 1/s
plus 1/Vmax.
Let's plot this.
I'm going to have 1/v and
here I'm going to have 1/s.
Now, if the concentration
of substrate
is really, really high, 1/s
is going to be almost zero.
So at the limit, when 1/s is
zero, then we should get v
equals Vmax.
So therefore, let's
say here it's 1/Vmax,
and therefore without
any inhibitor,
we're going to get a line
that looks like this.
Now, as we're adding an
inhibitor, this slope--
that is the coefficient or 1/s--
is going to be increasing.
Therefore, we should
get higher slopes.
The higher the concentration
of I, the bigger the slope.
So it's going to look like this.
So as concentration
of I increases,
the slope of this
graph will increase.
Notice however, that
all these lines,
even though correspond
to slower rates,
as the concentration of
substrate increases--
that is 1/s gets closer to 0--
they will all converge
to the same Vmax.
This is the key feature of
a competitive inhibition
because the substrate
in high quantities
can out compete the inhibitor.
Nevertheless, this
mechanism only
applies when the binding of
an inhibitor to the enzyme
is fast and reversible.
If the binding is
not reversible,
obviously the enzyme will
be inactivated forever,
and then we will see a
time dependent inactivation
of the enzyme.
The same phenomenon will happen
if the reverse reaction, that
is the dissociation of the
inhibitor from the enzyme,
is a slow process as well.
All these considerations
form a comprehensive answer
for part one of the problem.
Question two asked us to provide
several reasons for which
aldehyde inhibitors
are not actually
desirable as therapeutics.
Once again, we have to think
about the carbonyl chemistry.
We saw here that aldehydes
can react very well
with nucleophiles such
as thiols and thiolates.
But aldehydes in solution
can react with water and form
what we call geminal diols.
That look like this.
Therefore, the
effective concentration
of the aldehyde in solution
will be diminished because
of this equilibrium,
and that inhibitor
might not be efficient at
that lower concentration.
Another consideration involves
the oxidation of aldehydes.
These could be
enzymatically or even
non-enzymatically oxidized
to form carboxylic acids
or carboxylates.
These would obviously
not be very reactive
and any inhibitor
that gets oxidized
will stop being an inhibitor.
Additionally, owing
to their reactivity,
aldehyde group could react
with many other biomolecules.
Think about the amino
acid side chains.
Many of them are
actually, in fact,
capable of reacting
with aldehydes.
This will also diminish
the effective concentration
of the inhibitor and it may
even cause side effects.
Therefore taking all
these into considerations,
aldehydes may not be a great
solution for therapeutics.
Question 3 is asking us to
propose a mechanism by which
the second kind of inhibitor,
the acyloxymethyl ketone
is inhibiting the protease.
As you see here, the
acyloxymethyl ketone
is actually very similar
to the aldehyde inhibitor.
Notice this group
is exactly the same
as the carbonyl group
of the aldehyde,
but instead of having
just the hydrogen,
we have a methylene next to
a aryloxy or acyloxy group.
This, as you know, is a
very good leaving group
and provides a second reactive
site, this methyl group here,
that can react with the enzyme.
The second kind of
inhibitor is in fact
very similar to the tosyl,
phenyl, chloro ketone inhibitor
of serine proteases,
which is discussed
at length in the lecture
notes and in the book.
These inhibitors fall
in a general class
of alpha substituted
ketones and they
feature two reactive sites.
One is the carbonyl
and the other one
is the methylene group, which
has attached a good leaving
group.
Now, here is a general form
of a alpha substituted ketone.
Here is the ketone, here is
the methylene group attached
to a good leaving group,
which I'm going to denote x.
Now, here are the residues
in the active site.
Here is the cysteine
with the thiol group,
and here is the histidine,
which I'm going to draw out.
Histidine, all right.
So as we saw
before, the reaction
will start by the histidine
acting as a general base.
The histidine deprotonates
the cysteine, which then
can attack the ketone carbonyl.
This leads to the formation
of a tetrahedral intermediate.
And we have a positive
charge, here on the histidine,
and a negative charge
on the O minus, here.
Now, this tetrahedral
intermediate presumably
will be stabilized
in an oxyanion hole,
as you guys have seen before
with some kind of hydrogen
bonds to the backbone
of the protein.
Now, in the next step,
this is something
that you can't really
anticipate or know
without doing some experiments.
But it turns out this O minus
is a good SN2 nucleophile
to displace the good
leaving group, x.
So we're going to
have an S2 reaction,
This O minus attacks
the carbon, and then
the x takes the
electrons and leaves.
What we're going to
form here is an epoxide.
All right, so this
is the epoxide
and we still have our
protonated histidine here.
And there's a
positive charge here,
and of course, the x group is
taking its electrons and leaves
as an anion.
Now, in the next step, because
this is sitting actually
close enough to the
epoxide, the epoxide
is going to get protonated.
This takes the proton
from the histidine.
So now we have a
protonated epoxide,
and the histidine now is
in its deeper native form,
and the epoxide has
a positive charge.
Now, because we have
a protonated epoxide,
this acts as a very
good leaving group,
and this carbon becomes
very susceptible for an SN2
reaction.
And it turns out, the
histidine, this nitrogen,
is a good enough nucleophile to
react in an SN2 type reaction.
And in fact, the reaction is
helped by this other nitrogen.
I should have used
a different color.
So what we're
getting out here is
a covalent bond
between the histidine
and the alpha position of the
original alpha substituted
ketone.
Now, this reaction will not
be, in fact, reversible.
So we should just
say one arrow only.
So there we have our histidine.
Now it's covalently
attached to our inhibitor
and this step is, in
fact, irreversible.
So this prevents the
inhibitor from ever
dissociating once this
reaction has taken place.
Now, even though this
tetrahedral intermediate
around the carbonyl
carbon, it can fall apart
as we saw before,
reforming the carbonyl
and the cysteine thiol, the
covalent bond to the histidine
remains.
And this is, in fact, the reason
for which these inhibitors
are irreversible and will show
a time dependent inhibition.
Regardless of the more
complicated mechanistic detail
I just showed you,
the take home message
here is that when using an
alpha substituted ketone,
the end result will
be a covalent bond
between the enzyme
and the inhibitor
that is not reversible.
Therefore, we expect to see
a time dependent inactivation
of the enzyme.
The more enzyme is being
taken out of the reaction
by the inhibitor, the slower
the overall reaction will
be until there is no more enzyme
left to catalyze the reaction.
The problem also provides
some kinetic data,
which, in fact, supports the
time dependent inhibition
features of the second
kind of inhibitor.
In this figure, we see on
the y-axis, the concentration
of the product that is
formed, and on the x-axis
we see the time.
Now, if we look at the
dark circles, which
is the control
reaction in which we
have some substrate,
but no inhibitor,
we see that the product is
produced and increases linearly
with time.
However, once we
add the inhibitor
at a certain concentration, and
this would be the dark squares,
then we see that the amount of
product increases for a while,
but then it grows slower and
slower until it eventually
stops.
Now at this point, if we
add an excess of substrate,
we see that the reaction
does not restart,
meaning the entire amount of
enzyme has been inactivated,
and this inactivation
is irreversible.
However, we're also provided
this additional piece
of the data.
If we run the reaction in
an excess of substrate,
we see here the open circles,
the amount of product
produced increases
linearly with time.
But if we add the same
amount of inhibitor,
these open squares actually
are on top or right
next to the open circles
on this line, which
says that the inhibitor
has virtually no effect
at this level of concentration.
Which tells us
that the inhibitor
is in fact competing
with the substrate
and we will have an
excess of the substrate.
The inhibitor does not
get a chance to bind
and inhibit the enzyme, at least
within this interval of time.
Now this way of plotting
kinetic data is perhaps
a little misleading because
the amount of product
that we obtained
from the reaction
does not reflect how much of
the enzyme gets inhibited.
We want, in fact, to look at the
percentage of enzyme activity
that is remaining after
a given amount of time.
Therefore, if we were to
plot percentage enzyme
activity versus time,
for a controlled reaction
we expect the
reaction to proceed,
and the enzyme to stay
just as active at any given
point in time, so we
will see a straight line.
However, when we add
an inhibitor, which
shows a time
dependent inhibition,
then the percentage
enzyme activity
that remains at every point
in time will be decreasing.
And in fact, will be
decreasing to the point
that it reaches the
maximum of slope
for the maximum amount
of inhibitor present
in the reaction mixture.
So this line
represents the fastest
that the enzyme can be
completely inactivated
by an inhibitor.
It will be governed by
the binding affinity
of the inhibitor to the enzyme.
This answers the third and
last question of this problem.
I hope you enjoyed
this exploration
of the various strategies
by which inhibitors
can inhibit proteases.
This problem
highlights, in fact,
the importance of understanding
the mechanism of action
of enzymes.
Only then we can begin to
design therapeutically useful
inhibitors.